الان ننتقل مشاهدينا الى طهران وكلمه
لقائد الحرس الثوري الايراني حسين
سلامي ان اسلام در هم اسلام بود اما باز
هم باهم
ومتم سواء على الصعيد الكان الصهيوني او
على الصعيد الفصائل الارهابيه كلها
فشلت وكان لقائدنا البطل الشهيد قا
سلان آتش فشان
تر منتشر شده بود و بخش از بلاد اسلام را
در مانش خش رفته
بمس مسلم
راه المؤامرات
والمخططات سرر و قتل
عامرد مخططات هذه العصابات الارهابيه التي
خلقتها الولايات المتحده والتي كانت تقطع
الرؤوس
اختار
جنات
نشاهد ش هذا الكيان الصهيوني الذي فاقت
جرائمه جرائم داعش والعصابات الارهابيه في
عدوانه الغاشم على الشعب الفلسط من
0و نادا هستند دران لانه ها
سز
انهم
رون
جدران
فتان وخافون وخون
مواجهه سست آر ابطال المقاومه الاسلام ارض
فلسط ول به
آنها هشدار راده ونحن
نح شما ا ه هست ماقول
لرا زن ودان مظلوم و بف راش
لوتم رجالا حقا تعال وواجه بدل ان تقتلوا
الابر من النساء والاطفال مرد هست وانرد
لو كنتم رجالا حقا
اشهر
ول لم توا حقا من اشباه
الرجال
تعال با آن وقت شما را تحسن وسوف نمجد على
هذه الشجاعه
[موسيقى]
رو
اصحاب صبر و
استقامت عاجزون عن ذل
شما سنتمر
هستمر رحمت لعالم بود
ونفر الذ يدعون انهم من
اتباع الرسول
ب
دفاع صا
ش
[موسيقى]
قرآ
نن تقتل الاطفال الابر ونساء مر در قرآن
نمده
اج
[موسيقى]
اسراف
شما
مدن ان قتل طفل
بر يساو قتل الناس جمعا انتم الذ تقراون
القران و
تحفظونه هل
تم ان مع هر اصحاب
النب
اقتلوهم
حفتهم واقتلوهم حث
وجدتموهم
بدان با مفقود شدن با نا شدن نمتو از عذاب
اله بالاختفاء
وهروب
ان ا ه ان تتخلص من عذاب الله ولو عشتم ال
عام سوف
نجد
علي ا ا جميع الشعب الايران يجب ان يعرف
ويعلم اليوم اننا ناخذ حربا كبيره ونحن
صامدون فيها وسوف نهزمهم كل يوم وسوف
نذيقهم مراره
الهزيمه ولن نسمح لهم بان
يتقدموا قيد انمله بفضل الله وسوف نفتح
القلل
الجده
بفلس را بدان واعلم ضربات آنها
درفت ان
الضربات الت تدوها كانت ثقله ومؤلمه بو
امروز م لذلك نرى
اليوم السلطات
الصهيونيه لم يجد طريقا للتخلص من هذا
المستنقع فانهم اذا واصلوا سوف يهزموا
واذا وقفوا فانهم
مهزومون
ولكن المقاومه الاسلاميه هي بين احدى
الحسنيين فسواء استشهدت
ذا ما تغلبت عليكم فهي منتصره نحن اصحاب
الشهاده ونحن
رجال
المعركه ونحن لن نترك
الساحه انظروا الى هذه الحشود الب
فيمان فهذا الشعب ليس شعبا يخاف سرافراز
شما سرافراز
و ان
الشهاده شما تسلا رمان را دهد و شن ما هم
فرمان و ان الشهاده في سبيل الله فوزا
عظيما وان الشهاده في سبيل الله فوز
عظم واننا سوف نس مع صاحب
ست محترم جمهور اسلام ا احترام شما مردم
برمان و شهان والا
مقامان امروز دران شما حضور ستند مقدم
اشان را حضر ب هذه الجماه به شما ونشره
على هذا الحضور خادم وانا اقول لكم كخادم
لكم وجندي صغير للشعب الايران
المبار
واقبل
ايديكم والطريق الذي تمشون عليه واريد من
الله سبحانه وتعالى ان يعطيني الطاقه
الكبيره لكي اتحمل مسيكم
والام لكي تكونوا شامخين مرفوعي الراس
امام الله وامام العالم والسلام عليكم
ورحمه
الله